i don't know so you just wanted to hurt
you just wanted to hurt me and steve's
feeling no i just feel like like oasis
is it was so painfully commercial with
only a handful of songs that people i
mean they were those were the songs that
that was those were the songs that hit
the states yeah i'm always weary of
popular but everywhere else i'm telling
you yeah
i just didn't i listened to the the
lyrics the lyrics weren't that deep to
me
watch this have you heard her slide away
by the way
slide away at the lyrics just slide
around bring up the lyrics to slide away
all right cast no shadow
yeah
bring up i know that's like a way i know
it's just typing slide away and give it
all you got my today fell in from the
top i dream of you and all the things
you say i wonder where you are now hold
me down all the world's asleep i need
you now i need you to know you've
knocked me off my feet i dream of you
and we talk of growing old but you said
please don't
slide in baby together we'll fly i've
tried praying but i don't know just what
you're saying to me now that your mind
will find a way of chasing the sun
let me be the one who shines with you in
the morning we don't know what to do two
of a kind will find a way to do what
we've done let me be the one who shines
with you and we can slide away slide
away slide away by today fun from the
top
there you don't even have to go any
further do me a favor just bring up i'm
gonna bring up just maybe a couple songs
bring up uh she's the one springsteen
this was a song he wrote to a girl he
couldn't have
all right
i'll just let's just try this but i'm
going to give you another one with her
killer graces and her secret places that
no boy can fill and with her hands on
her hips oh and that smile on her lips
because she knows that it kills me with
that soft french cream standing in that
doorway like a dream i wish she'd just
leave me alone because french cream
won't soften them boots and french
kisses will not break that heart of
stone [ __ ] his first queen with a long
hair fall in her eyes that shine like
the midnight sun oh oh she's the one
and that thunder in your heart at night
when you're kneeling in the dark it says
you're never going to leave her but
there's an angel in her eyes that tells
such desperate lies and all you want to
do is believe her and tonight you'll try
just one more time to leave it all
behind and break on through but she can
take you and if she wanna break you
she's gonna find out it ain't so easy to
do and no matter where you sleep tonight
or how far you run
she's the one
okay what the [ __ ]
chin if you had to compare those lyrics
don't put me in this man they're both
great they're both great ah they're both
well
brian was super passionate about this
one yeah you noticed the way he read the
away right now this way this one bring
up growing up just bring up growing up
springsteen again yeah
i'm only starting with springsteen we
can get it
forget it
i'm just talking growing up
and now this is another song he was
running 24 when he wrote this
when i stood stone-like at midnight
suspended in my masquerade not comb my
hair till it was just right and i
commanded the night brigade and i was
open to pain and crossed by the rain and
i walked on a crooked crutch and i
strolled out all alone into a fallout
zone and came out with my soul untouched
and i hid in the clouded wrath of the
crowd when they when they said sit down
i stood up ooh ooh growing up and that
flag of piracy this is what it is to be
a young man
when when you're a kid and nobody
understands you that flag of piracy flew
from my mast and my sails were set wing
to wing i had a jukebox graduate for a
first mate she couldn't sell but she
sure could sing and i pushed 52 and
bombed him with the blues but my gear
set stubborn on standing i broke all the
rules strafed which means shot why don't
you read this all right i get the point
yeah
all right he's very passionate ah about
a lot of things wait go back go down go
down go downstairs oh this is my
favorite
watch this watch this ready this is
romantic listen to this all right i took
well i took month-long vacations in the
stratosphere and you know it's really
hard to hold your breath
i swear i lost everything i ever loved
or feared i was the cosmic kid in full
costume dress well my feet they finally
took root in the earth but i got me a
nice little place in the stars and i
swear i found the key to the universe in
the engine of an old parked car
listen listen come on [ __ ]
goddamn he was 22 you [ __ ]
growing up and i could just keep on
going
no
i'll go to [ __ ] youtube don't make
them go to you we don't need to go any
further
i just hate the way you read the lyrics
though yeah yeah yeah you read you read
those super you read those with [ __ ]
that man
power
i'll read anything you want from oasis i
mean i don't know because you're gonna
you're gonna read it like a jacket i'll
do it there you go no i'll give it a
second
give it up bring up who else i'll live
forever live forever i'm gonna give this
the same passion we'll live forever
watch my [ __ ] read i i i studied the
spoken word
i started live forever this is dedicated
to me because i'm basically [ __ ]
immortal all right
maybe i don't maybe i don't really want
to know how your garden grows because i
just want to fly lately did you even
ever feel the pain in the morning rain
as it soaks you to the bone maybe i just
want to fly i want to live i don't want
to die maybe i just want to breathe
maybe i just don't believe maybe the
same as me
we see things they'll never see you and
i are going to live forever i like this
i said maybe i don't want to really i
don't really want to know how your
garden grows because i just want to fly
lately did you ever feel the pain in the
morning rain as it soaks you to the bone
maybe i will never be all the things
that i want to be now
is not the time to cry now is the time
to find out why i think you're the same
as me we'll see things they'll never see
you and i are going to live forever
maybe i don't really want to know how
your garden grows that's right yeah all
right so all right so he's replete
eating a lot but that's literally it's
it's not bad it's nice it's beautiful
but you see how it lacks some depth
i mean it doesn't it doesn't
go deep you just but i do like that i do
but there's a lot going to live forever
we get it he's lucky i don't like to
argue with old people
i like that
i like to respect my elders no you know
what you know what this is the truth if
that [ __ ] moves you then that's true hey
what i thought was interesting that you
do uh
appreciate a lot of kanye's work i do
because i went down that rabbit hole
yeah because i wanted to see i i
made you curious well i listened to
people who know better and they were
explaining why kanye's special yeah why
he broke the mullet yeah so then when
you start when you lit when you study it
and then you listen to the music from
that perspective
that that dude
is a groundbreaker
and so then how are you going to be
because as a as a old white dude i
didn't grow up with rap really yeah you
know you you can be just ignorant to
true artistry i want to know who my
artistic heroes are as they walk around
you understand that's the other thing
about keeping in mind is that we live in
a time when you got to put people up on
a pedestal